♪
>> Greg: YEAH, YOU BETTER
CLAP.
SO AFTER TUESDAY'S DEMOCRATS
BLOODBATH, YOU SEE MORE
FINGER-POINTING THAN ANNA
JOHNNY DEPP DIVORCE.
AND MOST OF IT IS DIRECTED AT
ALL THOSE, EVIL, WHITE PEOPLE.
RIGHT?
>> THIS IS ISN'T ABOUT
ENTHUSIASM.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT DEMOCRATS
DOING ENOUGH TO EXERCISE THEIR
BASE AND IT DEFINITELY IS NOT
ABOUT -- THIS IS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT A GOOD CHUNK OF VOTERS OUT
THERE ARE OKAY WITH WHITE
SUPREMACY.
LET'S CALL A THING A THING
ACTUALLY, SCRATCH THAT.
>> Greg: SCRATCH WHAT?
THAT'S KIND OF GROSS.
MAYBE GET AN OINTMENT.
SO YEAH, DEMOCRATS LOST BECAUSE
VOTERS LOVE WHITE SUPREMACY.
ESPECIALLY THE 54% OF HISPANIC
WHITE SUPREMACIST WHO VOTED FOR
YOUNGKIN.
THOSE HISPANIC WHITE SUPREMACIST
AGAIN WITH HER WHITE SUPREMACIST
TANGO AND WHITE SUPREMACIST
TAMALES.
YOU'VE HEARD THIS WHITE
SUPREMACIST ALL OVER AT MSNBC.
THIS NETWORK WAS THE WORST IDEA
BILL GATES EVER HAD BESIDES
HANGING OUT WITH
JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID HANGING.
ANYWAY -- TOO SOON.
THAT PLACE, THAT NO WORK LIES TO
THEIR VIEWERS MORE THAN THE GUY
WHO SOLD ME THOSE BLUE PILLS ON
CRAIGSLIST.
ROCK-HARD MY.
BUT THEY BLAME WHITENESS FOR
VIRGINIA'S ELECTION WHILE SAYING
CRT DOES NOT EXIST.
IT MAKES YOU MISS THE CLINTON
ERA WHEN THE DEMS WERE VERY GOOD
AT LYING.
SO CROSS WAS FILLING IN FOR THE
HOME OHMIC BLOGGER REED WHO HAD
SAID THE SAME THING.
>> IT WAS EDUCATION, WHICH IS
CODE FOR WHITE PARENTS DON'T
LIKE THE IDEA OF TEACHING ABOUT
RACE.
>> YES, BECAUSE THERE IS ONE
THING MISSING IN OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM, IT IS AMERICA'S HISTORY
OF RACISM.
WHAT IS MISSING AND THE STRIP
CLUB IS THE SMELL OF
DESPERATION.
AND BABY POWDER.
IT IS FUNNY, THOUGH.
HOW COULD SOMEONE NAMED JOY REID
BE SO JOYLESS AND NOT TO READ?
THERE ARE COUNTLESS ARTICLES OUT
THERE ON CRT AND HOW OFTEN IT IS
BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS.
SO JOY AND TIFFANY THE SAME
THING LIKE PEOPLE WHO PLANNED A
LIE OFTEN WELL.
IT'S LIKE TO MSNBC ONLY HAVE ONE
BRAIN AND IN THE HANDOFF THEY
MUST'VE DROPPED IT NUMEROUS
TIMES.
BUT WHAT IF THEY ARE RIGHT?
IN FACT, THERE ARE A LOT OF
VOTERS WHO ARE OKAY WITH WHITE
SUPREMACY.
IT'S JUST THAT THEY VOTE
DEMOCRAT.
AND NOT BECAUSE THE SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR WHO EITHER WORE
BLACKFACE OR A CLIENT HOOD.
HE NEVER DID TELL US WHICH.
EITHER WAY, NO WHITE SHEETS
AFTER LABOR DAY, RALPH.
IT'S OKAY TO LAUGH AT THAT.
OKAY, DON'T LAUGH.
BUT THE MOST AFFLUENT PLACES IN
AMERICA ARE ARLINGTON, FAIRFAX,
AND LOUDOUN COUNTY.
THEIR PEOPLE MAKE SIX OR EVEN
SEVEN FIGURES.
THE TYPE OF FOLKS WHO CAN AFFORD
HUNTER BIDEN'S ARTWORK AND DRUG
HABIT.
AND THEY VOTE DEMOCRAT
OVERWHELMINGLY KNOWING THAT IT
ONLY LEADS TO PAYING MUCH HIGHER
TAXES.
AS THE NEW YORK TIME POINTS OUT,
AFFLUENT SUBURBS WENT BLUER THAN
A SMIRK CHOKING ON A MARBLE.
THEY DIDN'T SAY THAT, I DID.
BUT THAT WON 77% OF THE VOTE IN
ARLINGTON SO THESE ARE VOTERS
WHO KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO PLAY
WAY MORE UNDER A DEMOCRAT BUT
THEY DO IT EITHER WAY WHETHER
INTACT SIZE, AT THE GAS PUMP, OR
BY MEDICAL DEVICES ONLINE.
FYI, CATHETERS COME IN HANDY
WHEN YOU CAN'T MAKE IT TO THE
BATHROOM.
TRUST ME.
SO WHILE TALK ABOUT ISSUES
MATTER TO BLACKS, NO MATTER TO
THESE RICH, WHITE, LIBERAL
RACISTS.
IF YOU VOTED REPUBLICAN, ARE YOU
TRYING TO SAVE SOME MONEY SO YOU
CAN FILL YOUR TANK WITH GAS OR
ARE YOU A RACIST?
MAYBE EVERYONE WHO DRIVES IS
RACIST.
BUT THE RICH WHITE LIBERAL
RACIST CAN AFFORD STUFF LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE SPENDING,
DEFENDING THE COPS, ON MITIGATED
REGULATION
--
BUT NO ONE ELSE CAN.
JUST WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
BLACKS VOTED AGAINST REPLACING
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
GETTING WIND OF THE POLICE IS A
POPULAR IDEA WITH WHITE COLLEGE
KIDS IN SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS BUT
NOT SO MUCH WITH PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT BE MURDERED.
UNLIKE WORKING-CLASS BLACKS,
RICH WHITE LIBERAL RACIST, THEY
CAN HANDLE IT.
WHEN YOU'RE WHITE AND RICH, YOU
CAN VOTE FOR ANYTHING THAT WILL
DESTROY AN URBAN AREA FASTER
THAN A CASE OF WHIPPETS ON KAT'S
BRAIN CELLS.
YOU CAN RAISE TAXES ON THE WHITE
LIBERAL RACIST.
THEY CAN HANDLE IT.
YOU CAN DEFUND OF THE POLICE,